now video has emerged appearing to show
the prime minister's former press
spokeswoman allegra stratton and some of
her downing street colleagues are
laughing and joking about a christmas
party number 10 denies ever happened
during severe covert restrictions last
year
i had just seen reports from twitter
that there was a downing street
christmas party on friday night do you
recognize those reports
i went home
hold on
uh
uh
would the prime minister condone uh how
are you chris
what's the answer i don't know i didn't
wasn't the party it was cheese and
wasn't clear
there's cheese from mine all right it
was a business meeting
joking this is recording
this fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
um one more and then one more
uh deputy political editor sam coates is
in the studio with me now sam uh allegra
stratton there we've heard her talking
about that party despite the denials
just how serious is this now for the
government and the prime minister well
it feels potentially really quite
serious tonight for about the last week
downing street have denied that there
was a party uh in downing street on
december the 18th now december the 18th
last year was two days after
serious restrictions were introduced in
london known back then as tier three
they banned indoor gatherings if you
remember uh yet we understand that quite
a large group of people gathered in
number 10 on that evening now normally
there might have been around about a
dozen people in downing street at that
point of time
but maybe as many as two or three dozen
maybe as many as 40
people were in dennis street that night
apparently for a christmas party that's
what sources have told us and other
media outlets
now for the last seven days danny street
have said no rules were broken even
though a party would breach the rules
and yesterday they said there was no
party yet tonight it appears that in the
final days of 2020 uh downing street
employees were joking about exactly that
party now the exchange you just heard
was between allegra stratton who was
going to become the face of boris
johnson's government as her on camera
spokeswoman and a junior employee called
ed oldfield and ed oldfield is talking
about reports of rumors about a
christmas party in downing street uh
that were appearing on twitter now i
don't think there were any tweets to
that effect he appears to be referring
to the party that we've been reporting
on for the last seven days or so uh an
allegra stratton
interestingly says i went home early uh
suggesting that she was briefly there
before uh before returning
and that would therefore appear to
contradict the denial given by downing
street yesterday that there was no party
now i think that this raises big
questions about credibility for downing
street for boris johnson questions about
this party uh have talked him all week
it will revive the labour attack that
there is one rule for boris johnson uh
and uh members of his government and one
rule uh for for everybody else and i
think that there is a nervousness
amongst conservative mps one uh tory mp
tonight described the footage that they
uh saw
of allegra stratton basically making the
government's position
indefensible that was his word and the
question is if they don't tell the truth
on this what else might they not be
telling the truth on that was his worry
uh that this will contaminate uh downing
street uh and it will undermine boris
johnson so downing street at the moment
sticking to their denial that there was
a party or that there was any uh rule
breaking but tonight with downing street
employees joking about an event that
number 10 deny happens is looking quite
bad for boris johnson